[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es mal wieder eine motiv
torte ja vor mir steht eine motiv torte
und kennen fast also kein echtes ja was
hätte geglaubt was ist nichts neues
sondern etwas weiß es ist besondere also
morgen wird mein bruder 40 jahre alt
jung besser gesagt und er weiß auch noch
nichts davon und wir sind eingeladen und
da habe ich gedacht jetzt muss ich ihm
aber eine torte machen
dann habe ich mir gedacht weil er ja
immer dich fertig machte ihn beschimpft
hat ja immer morath ja weil er ist
elektriker ja und ich sagte mir so das
zeug aus baunatal ja und er macht hat
der markt dem match moral das kann man
doch nicht machen genauso machen und
fasst auch er
und dann haben halt gedacht yamaha 40
jahre er machte man fass aufmachen wir
halten fast genauso aus wie das so wenn
man älter wird also umso älter sein sagt
man stimmt zwar nicht aber man sagt ist
umso besser wird daher natürlich nicht
toll wirklich besser der wird schlimmer
nein der wird immer besser
ok wird für seine frau wahrscheinlich
bestätigen können jedenfalls habe ich
hier ein fast ein weinfass aber ich wohl
sagen dieses etwas drastisch fantastisch
genau und hier vorne also mal erkennt ja
nicht auf den ersten blick dass es eine
geburtstagstorte ist aber ich hier vorne
das etikett ist das entscheidende das
ist nämlich ein edler tropfen jahrgang
1967 jedes fast rallye ist der name vom
wein
das ist ein qualitätswein und da ist
sehr lieblich ich habe noch überlegt ich
habe trocken unterschiedlich oder
halbtrocken aber nicht ich hab gedacht
kommentar oder das sind dann machen wir
leblich vom weingut waghäusel denn hier
bei uns in der kirche ist das weingut
und 24.6 ist das datum und natürlich
abgefüllt von berlin
du willst also dein bruder ab nein ich
hab das war einfach nur abgefilmt okay
aber genau beschreibt beim bruder genug
jetzt zum inneren der tat ich habe hier
einen schokokuchen mein bruder ist ein
totaler schock ofen das hat sich aber
den schoko teig gebacken ich habe meine
herren schokoladen
als eine richtig dunkle bitterschokolade
und das ganze dann noch mit schokoladen
fondant eingedeckt das heißt innen
schoko außen schoko die torte ist
wirklich super lecker du darfst später
sogar probieren auch wenn wir die tore
nicht abschneiden und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal wie ich die torte
hergestellt habe die tortenböden habe
ich schon vorbereitet und hier seht ihr
jetzt gleich alles was ihr dazu eher
tragischen nicht so perfekten übergang
gemacht in euren charakter noch mal rein
und fast war ja etwas folgen
was ist so eigentlich unfassbar borat
wie wär's mal mit abend ufa studios werk
übergang und hier zeige ich euch jetzt
was wir für die torte benedikt fast
hastig für die dort habe ich schon etwas
vorbereitet und zwar habe ich jetzt
schon mal die kuchen wurden gebacken und
weil ich jetzt gestern keine zeit dazu
hatte habe ich sie auch schon vorgestern
zubereitet ich habe ich jetzt die
schokoladen böden
da hab ich jetzt sechs stück ich habe
einmal die durchmesser von 18 cm 2 stück
treuen stück mit 16 und zwei steht mit
14 wobei ich die kleinen wahrscheinlich
gar nicht brauchen werde
aber das war immer so viel habe ich
gedacht kommen mag ich die auch noch mit
und der vorteil davon ist dass die jetzt
schön kalt sind ich hatte sie im
kühlschrank hat es in frischhaltefolie
eingewickelt und jetzt kann ich sie
gleich schön zurecht schneiden dann habe
ich jetzt hier noch einen kaffee
rausgelassen
hier habe ich noch ein bisschen
aprikosenmarmelade fein passiert und
ohne stückchen und natürlich auch eine
garage gestellt also die
schokoladencreme dieses mal mit herrn
schokoladen mein mann wohl ich sage mein
bruder der markt nämlich herren
schokolade auch sehr und liebt
schokokuchen und das wird so ein
shooting schokokuchen das erinnert dann
so ein bisschen an sachertorte zuerst
nehme ich jetzt die tortenböden und
schneidet jetzt mit der torten pflege
durch und je nach höhe könnte sie jetzt
drei oder vier mal oder durchschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch mal ganz grob wie
die torte gleich aussehen wird und es
ist auch ganz gut wenn ihr die vorher
erst einmal zusammensetzt das heißt hier
einfach mal drauf setzen dann seht ihr
auch wie hoch die torte ist ob ihr
wirklich alle tortenböden braucht jetzt
kommt unten der kleine teil
das soll er das fass werden das heißt am
ende sieht die torte eher so aus und das
ist ja nicht gerade sondern hat einen
dicken bauch gehen damit und geht oben
da wieder so ein bisschen dünner zu
jetzt erkennt man hier ganz gut schon
mal die form damit ich die torte gleich
gut bewegen kann nämlich ja in kate und
bestreicht es jetzt mit etwas garage so
klebt der erste boden schon mal gut dran
und die torte für huth stand einfach
auch nicht das kommt hier der erste
boden drauf jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm
dass es ein bisschen größer ist denn der
wird das sowieso gleich zugeschnitten
jetzt nehme ich den kaffee trinkt die
böden mit einem pinsel damit streicht
dann etwas von der aprikosenmarmelade
drauf und dann die garage und so bietet
die komplette torte geführt
[Musik]
jetzt steht schon mal die grundstruktur
und hier oben brauche ich jetzt erstmal
nichts drauf streichen und musste dort
jetzt erst einmal für mindestens eine
stunde wichtig danach schon fest ist
denn dann hat die torte die stabilität
und dann kann ich sie auch zu schneiden
in der zeit mache ich hier kurz sauger
und zeigt euch dann wie wir mit der deko
anfangen
[Musik]
ich habe hier schon mal modelle
schokolade weiß geknetet und zwar werden
jetzt daraus die trauben geformt das
muss ich erst mal die farbe mischen
ich nehme jetzt grün und weiß und mich
stolz und hellgrün für helle tragen und
dann nehme ich etwas blau ein bisschen
rot und bisschen schwarz für die dunklen
trauben und dann sollte der farbton
packung
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen becker
stärke bereits auf die arbeitsfläche
gegeben und jetzt nehme ich von der
modelle schokolade immer kleine
stückchen und formt daraus trauben
[Musik]
die trauben dürfen jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen trocken
als nächstes habe ich jetzt hier blüten
passte und daraus mache ich jetzt das
etikett für das weinfest und das soll
ich jetzt auf becker stärke ganz schön
aus und nehme jetzt auch blüten passte
weil man die eben wirklich super dünn
ausrollen kann und weil blüten passt
auch sehr schnell trocknet
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr einen pizzaschneider
oder ein messer oder zum beispiel auch
wie ich ein bisschen glück nehmen und
damit dann ein rechteck so schnell
[Musik]
damit das etikett auch ein bisschen alt
aussieht soll ja aus dem jahr 1977 sein
als 40 jahre alt mach ich jetzt hier die
ecken also die runde hat so ein bisschen
ab und später bruder ist dann noch und
dann sieht es auch wirklich alt und sein
mitgenommen aus wobei mein bruder
natürlich nicht war fehlte city gibt und
es liegt jetzt einfach kurz zur seite
damit wird was an trocknen kann
ich habe ich jetzt ein stück blüten
passt soll mit gelb und grüner passten
farbe eingefärbt und daraus werde ich
jetzt gleich blätter ausstechen
das heißt es jetzt erst mal drin aus und
die farbe ist jetzt schon grasgrün aber
später werde ich noch mit pulver farbe
arbeiten dass jetzt auch ein bisschen
realistischer aus
[Musik]
jetzt hab ich hier verschiedene blätter
ausstecher falls er keine habt könnt ihr
auch ganz einfach mit einem messer so
eine form ausschneiden und das ganze
dann auch noch so ein bisschen
strukturieren
[Musik]
und damit die blätter ein bisschen
realistischer aussehen nämlich jetzt
hier so ein schaumstoff pad und einem
whirlpool und jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen dünner streichen und dann nehme
ich noch model werkzeug und tritt sie so
ein bisschen ein so dass sich auch die
adern erkennen kann
[Musik]
die weintrauben liter lasse ich jetzt
hier auf der alu folie ein bisschen
trocknen so werden sie nicht nur glatt
sondern haben auch so ein bisschen
struktur
ich habe ich jetzt ein bisschen schwarz
weiß geknetet und zwar 500 gramm
schwarzen fondant und habe noch ein
bisschen blüten passte bricht das könnte
ich jetzt ein und überzieht damit dann
das skateboard und den fahndern knete
ich jetzt nicht ganz durch sondern dreht
ihn einfach ein paar mal so habe ich
eine leichte schiefe optik
[Musik]
und damit die frontplatte also diese
ausgerollte von der platte dank nämlich
ein bisschen s-bahn kleber und
streichelt das cache bot damit ein
[Musik]
und damit die platte ist nicht zu glatt
ist sondern auch ein bisschen stein
mäßig aussieht nämlich nochmal alufolie
und fallt ihr ein bisschen zusammen
das kann das jetzt ein bisschen struktur
wählen
[Musik]
und wenn euch die struktur dann gefällt
schlägt diese einfach zum trocknen auf
die seite
[Musik]
die deko ist es weitestgehend
vorbereitet jetzt geht es mit der fast
worte weiter
dies ist schön durch gekühlt ich habe
ich jetzt einen teller für die reste
also zum naschen und jetzt werde ich
anhand meiner vorlage einfach das was zu
schneiden das heißt in der mitte etwas
bauträger und oben und unten ein
bisschen spitze
[Musik]
darunter habe ich ein kleines skateboard
und dieses habe ich jetzt auch noch
einmal und es kann ich jetzt auch zur
hilfe nehmen obendrauf stellen muss man
nur aufpassen dass direkt darüber liegt
und so sehe ich dann auch wo ich das
ganze jetzt wegschneiden muss so dass es
fast nicht schief wird falls es doch ein
bisschen schliefe das ist gar nicht
schlimm dass ich am holzfass und es ist
damit handgemacht und daher darf das
auch ruhig ein paar macken haben und die
ganzen lücken hier zwischendrin fühle
ich dann wieder mit dem kuchen auf das
heißt ich nehme dann die ghanas zu hilfe
und klebt das ganze einfach wieder dran
[Musik]
ich stelle die torte so etwas kühl so
wird dieses stück hier ein bisschen fest
da kann ich wieder weg schneiden und
dann nehme ich dicker maß werdet die
erste schicht drauf machen das ist dann
sozusagen die krümel zu werden die
krümel gebunden stellt die torte
zwischendurch immer mal wieder kühl und
streicht sie dann mit der restlichen
ganache wirklich vollständig glatt die
zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt immer aus
um die deko fertigzustellen
hier mache ich jetzt zuerst die blätter
sie sehen jetzt im moment noch nicht so
ganz realistisch aus das ganze erreiche
ich jetzt durch pulver farbe hier habe
ich jetzt einen dunkelgrünen hellgrün
und zum dunkelroten ton können wir auch
brown nehmen jetzt nehme ich einfach
einen trockenen pinsel und wird sie
jetzt ganz trocken damit begann
[Musik]
ich blätterte nicht so weit fertig jetzt
geht's ans etikett und ich habe mir hier
schon mal eine vorlage gemacht damit ich
einfach was drauf kommt ich schreibe
jetzt drauf edler tropfen dann den
jahrgang natürlich 1977 den namen als
ali und dann steht da noch qualitätswein
usw
und das ganze mache c mit einem
lebensmittel farbstift mit dem werde ich
jetzt alles erstmal drauf zeichnen und
dann nehme ich hier die pulver farbe und
macht das etikett so ein bisschen auf
alt und wird dann noch möchte kann dann
ein bisschen metallic farben nehmen und
den schriftzug einfach noch ein bisschen
pfeiler gestalten
[Musik]
die obere hälfte der fragen habe ich
jetzt schon mal schön geformt und jetzt
schaue ich auch ob das fast schön gerade
ist das heißt mit der wasserwaage und so
stelle ich jetzt erstmal in den
kühlschrank für etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
bis sie schön festes denn dann kann ich
das was umdrehen und die obere hälfte
eben auch mal bestreiten
als man die hände sauber
[Musik]
die tat habe ich jetzt glatt gestrichen
und dafür hab ich am ende einfach die
hände genommen
so kann ich nämlich diese schöne
rundungen mit den händen nach fangen
jetzt muss ich natürlich da oben die
platte wegnehmen
ihr könntet ort im prinzip noch mal
umdrehen aber muss man gar nicht dann
oben und unten ist sie jetzt gleich
jetzt die platte oben wegnehmen ganz
vorsichtig und dann kann ich da oben
nochmal ganache drauf streichen und dann
kommt nämlich schon von dann drauf
[Musik]
die tat ab jetzt glatt gestrichen und im
prinzip kann ich jetzt hier schon die
holzoptik machen das heißt hier kommt
jetzt von dann drüber
normalerweise wollte ich jetzt nur eine
schicht machen aber da wir gerade sehr
heiß draußen haben und ich denke auch
dass die torte morgen bestimmt mal eine
halbe stunde in der luft also nicht in
der luft steht aber auf dem tisch steht
und es sehr warm wird da hätte ich jetzt
angst dass die holzlatten runterrutschen
das heißt ich mache jetzt eine basis
schicht drauf mit fondant und da habe
ich jetzt schon schoko fondant dünn
ausgerollt
das sage ich jetzt ein kilo hassbecker
stärker ausgerollt und werde jetzt die
torte nehmen einmal damit einschlagen
und danach kommt noch die zweite schicht
drüber und das ist dann die deckschicht
damit davon dann jetzt gut hält kommt
jetzt ein bisschen back transport drauf
sowie die oberfläche einfach wieder ein
bisschen feucht jetzt lege ich hier
vorsichtig die von wand decke drüber
das muss jetzt auch nicht so genau sein
wenn da jetzt mal löcher entstehen ist
es auch nicht schlimm
und jetzt mit den händen ein bisschen
platt streichen und nach unten hin immer
den vom land weg ziehen damit die falten
einfach verschwinden
[Musik]
da wird schon mal hier die basis schicht
glatt gestrichen
und jetzt werde ich die torte noch mal
kurz kühlen den restlichen schoko von
dann wieder weich kneten und auch ein
bisschen vanille von hand nehmen und
damit machen wir jetzt gleich so eine
richtig schöne holzmaserung wir
zusätzlich die torte auf das skateboard
drauf nicht ganz mittig sondern eher ein
bisschen weiter hinten
damit ich vorne noch ein bisschen platt
habe jetzt gar nicht die torte auch noch
so anfassen war draufsetzen
einmal habe ich jetzt hier noch das
skateboard was perfect oben drauf passt
das heißt da brauche ich einmal sperre
die portion und den rest schneide ich
jetzt in bahnen und das mache ich jetzt
mit dem bisher klett aber ihr könnt auch
einfach ein messer oder eine pizza hut
nehmen
und jetzt sitze ich hier noch mit brille
werkzeug ein holzstruktur ein das heißt
ein paar kleine löcher und dann noch
einfach so streifen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier die schöne
holzstruktur und jetzt kann ich die
einzelnen latten zuschneiden und an den
rand und an die oberfläche kleben bei
der oberfläche ist ganz hilfreich
entweder die skateboard zu nehmen oder
einen teller in der größe damit einmal
schön außenrum schneiden kann ich kann
jetzt glaub ich sogar den bug ring dafür
benutzen
das heißt ich mache jetzt erstmal die
oberseite versuchen wir jetzt hier
direkt geeignete stelle raus am besten
hier am rand um nicht zu viel zu
verschwenden dann die latten schön
gerade hinlegen und einmal aus die
werden jetzt mit kleber mit dem s bahn
kleber einfach auf die oberfläche
geklebt und den kleber geht es hier auch
einen zähler und kann dann mit dem
pinsel schön auftragen
[Musik]
letzte reihe und bei der letzten ist so
natürlich könnt ihr das bisschen
schlauer machen als ich ihr könnt die
letzte reihe nach hinten legen dann hat
ja hinten dem abschluss aber das ist
auch vorne gar nicht schlimm ich zeige
euch nämlich gleich wie man das hier
vorne dann anpasst ich habe jetzt immer
auch mit den fingern so wissen die
lücken geschlossen aber teilweise auch
offen gelassen weil ich finde das macht
ebenso realistisch sieht habe ich hier
zum beispiel den bauch und da kann ich
das hier leicht zusammendrücken und hier
oben schneide ich einfach ein bisschen
was weg
[Musik]
die übrige becker strecke nämlich jetzt
mit einem trockenen pinsel weg und damit
das holz fast ein bisschen realistischer
aussieht nehme ich jetzt noch mal
trockenpulver fahre und pulver dann
betritt
[Musik]
den fast reifen hier habe ich jetzt aus
schwarzer models schokolade gemacht und
einfach mit zucker kleber drum geklebt
und jetzt nehme ich hier noch eine
spritze das ist eine lok hülle und das
sind das britische synthie mieten diese
kleinen
[Musik]
und der glanz kommt jetzt durch die
essbare metallic farben
[Musik]
jetzt wird die torte fertig dekoriert
das heißt die trauben und alles was ich
vorbereitet habe kommt jetzt hier drauf
ich habe jetzt nicht so viele trauben
geformt deswegen habe ich jetzt hier ein
stück modelle schokolade
da ist die farbe vollkommen egal streich
jetzt ein bisschen kleber dran und
moritz klar als ich mogel jetzt ein
bisschen das heißt hier so eine kleine
grundstruktur haben schon mal so die
werbung und dann kann ich jetzt die
trauben drumherum kleben
[Musik]
als ich muss sagen die torte gefällt mir
richtig gut
ja na schön schlicht und trotzdem die so
elegant ich finde die falsche person
bekommt aber egal
letztes jahr haben sie ihm ein buch
gemacht also falls ihm eine bucht orte
sucht könnt ihr euch gerne auch das buch
anschauen können wir hier verlinken und
dieses mal ein fast und jetzt probieren
wir die torte natürlich aber weil ich
die torte ist nicht anschneiden möchte
habe ich vorhin einfach aus den resten
hier
diese torte gezaubert das heißt die
böden die ich nicht gebraucht habe
einfach zusammengesetzt mit der
restlichen creme das darfst du das
probieren die nachbarskinder und spaß
draußen ja mit der sanierung laut ok
sagt da fehlt jetzt nur die
aprikosenmarmelade der wir jetzt da
vergessen weil die bringt nämlich soweit
die macht das ganze sowieso wieder
saftig genauer training wird sagen genau
kuchen ist jetzt halt getränke und ja
ich halt nicht mehr alles also trockener
ist nicht trocken wie folgt aber ist
halt nicht so wie nicht so wie du da
drin also da fehlt jetzt ein bisschen
der die aprikosen monate und den ihr
problem sie dann morgen soll es sein das
du kraft rein gemacht nicht aus ich will
das rausholt herren schokolade und
kaffee tee kaffee umsonst ich habe mit
wasser getränkt new york wird mal im
kuchen summen jeweils ist ja
wahrscheinlich
und falls ihr jetzt auch dieses fast
nach machen möchtet dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei da stehen die genaue
mengenangaben und ich hoffe dass ich
dieses was gefällt und ihr die torte auf
jeden fall mal nachmachen werden zumal
man kann ja alles machen kann ein
bierfass machen ein weinfass zwar kann
was kann man noch alles machen das gibt
es oft fest
ihr habt bestimmt auch noch ganz viele
tolle ideen und ich wünsche euch jetzt
mal ganz viel spaß dabei viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
ich mach's gut du hast du schade jetzt
zu verschenken
ok kostet geschaffene kunstwerke auf
essen motor show
[Musik]